hello everyone I had a couple of
requests already to show a game by Maya
too but then it said Maya was a seventh
Women's World Chess Champion and until
2010 she was the youngest woman to ever
hold this title until it was broken in
2010 by holy fun and Maya is the second
woman ever to achieve the title of
Grandmaster afternoon I got put in -
really this game was played in 1983 it
was played in Dortmund and the Maya has
the white pieces against Nigel short my
style is very solid but also very
aggressive as you'll see in this game
and although it's not the most precise
game her style is complicated enough to
confuse a player of Nigel's strength so
my place Knight to c3 the van gate
opening we have d5 and E for transposing
into the close Scandinavian D captures
on e4 Knight captures on e4 and now
Knight to f6 Knight captures on f6 and
we have G captures on f6 and d4 c6 by
Nigel and this is not the best move to
be played in this position this move
will give nigel problems later on I move
like e5 was preferred here Bishop to e2
now Queen to c7 Knight to f3 and the
Bishop to g4 Maya plays c4 and East six
by Nigel Maya castles we have Knight to
d7 and d5 it's very interesting that
Tamiya isn't afraid of the open G file
as her style is very aggressive so she's
not really bothered by this and in this
position
well I move like Queen to c2 or maybe h3
would be considered by many players but
she goes for the aggressive and
straightforward d5 we have queenside
castle by Nigel and now probably Bishop
to e3 would give my sufficient game as
this this does leave white with some
advantage the it's a simple development
for move it comes into the game with a
tempo but instead that Bishop to e3 she
goes for the more straightforward D
captures on e6 and this is
well this is a mistake it allows Nigel
to play Knight to e5 opening up a
discovered attack from the rook to the
Queen and also this Knight is
threatening all sorts of jumps from here
Maia defends this with Knight - d - now
opening up an attack - this bishop on g4
twice and this is well a critical moment
in the game and Nigel should definitely
have played h5 and this locks this
bishop in on g4 beautifully a move like
Bishop characters ng for allowing H
captain g4 and the white is lost here
the open H file the Queen eyeing in on
the H - this Knight is ready to jump
into the game the bishop is ready to
jump into d6 into c5 this would be
terrible for white
so after this h5 move there's really no
way to get this Bishop out of g4 and
it's an extremely strong piece there you
could weaken your position further with
a move like f3 or h3 although on h3 this
threat might even be you know
disregarded as the bishop might even be
sacrificed but after this night the d2
move nigel got a little bit
materialistic he didn't go for h5 he
played Bishop captures on e6 getting the
bishop away from this strong g4 square
and allowing Maia to consolidate we have
a queen to a for my immediately jumps
into the attack now eyeing this a
7-point with the Queen but now Nigel
doesn't really care about the a 7-point
please rook the g8 and well capturing
the a7 point is something of a personal
preference if you came up to the a
7-point you're allowing Bishop to h3 at
the threat is rook captures and g2 and
here a move like g3 would have to be
played and well you lose the exchange
here Bishop captures an f1 and the
Knight captures an f1 and well white is
down the exchange and he did open up the
King's position a little bit but you
don't have any real resources to attack
the black king so this could go either
way
although black is definitely better here
so after rook to g8 Maya plays Knight to
e4
with the ideas of 90 to f6 and also now
Bishop to h3 isn't really possible
because Knights can simply defend this
would night to g3 we have Bishop
captures on c4 by Nigel and Mayas
position is actually pretty bad here
Nigel's idea is pretty simple if we
captured a bishop for example Bishop
captures on c4 you lose immediately to
Knight to f3 check the g2 pawn is pinned
after King to h1 Queen captures on h2
this is checkmate
so after Bishop to c4 it's definitely a
difficult position for Maya but she
finds a way to complicate things
she plays Bishop to h5 a pretty weird
move I mean the king is all the way on
it on c8 what is Bishop to h5 but she's
definitely allowing Nigel to capture the
rook and f1 this is the best move and
Nigel display it so Bishop captures an
f1 we have King captures an f1 and well
okay the little Plus that is being down
the exchange is that the King is no
longer on g1 so Knight to f3 is no
longer any significant threat night the
d3 by Nigel and we have Queen captures
an a7 Queen to e5 great move by Nigel
now attacking the knight also preparing
to get the bishop into the game but here
Maya plays Bishop to e3 totally
disregarding the fact that Nigel just
attacked her Knight and this is
definitely the the second critical
moment of the game the best move for
Nigel here is Bishop to e7 nigel should
have played this this is connecting the
rooks the bishop is earning more
protection to the rook on the 8th and
the King has a nice escape route with
King to d7 and King to e8 if needed but
instead after Bishop to e3 Nigel said
you don't really have anything here and
he captured the night and this was a
mistake of Queen captures any fort was
played by Nigel and here comes Queen to
a8 with check King to c7 and now Bishop
to b6 with check sacrificing another
piece so King captures an b6 and our
Queen captures and the
with check the king goes to c5 and here
we had before with check King character
Sam before it was played and we had
Bishop to f3 and this is the last
critical moment of the game
nigel should have played Queen to c4 and
the game goes on black can play this but
nigel played the Queen to e5 and well
from here there is no turning back
rook to be one check a nigel defense
with knights to be two we have Queen to
d2 with check King to a3 and here is the
problem
rook captures on be too and I'm sure
Nigel was very sad when he saw this
because capturing the rook with the
Queen leads the Queen to a5 with
checkmate so after rook to be - Nigel
cried b5 looked the b3 check King to a4
and here
Bishop to d1 in this position and I
short resign the game as well this rook
is threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries just he doesn't even have to
win the Queen for example if I move like
before is played simply wrote capture
some before and after a move like King
to a5 rope the B to check King has to go
to a6 Bishop to e2 check King a7 now
Queen to d7 check you can give up the
Queen but there's really no point to
this King 2a 8a now Queen - b7 checkmate
this is one a nice one nice King walk
from eat from I ate all the way to a
three and then all the way to a eight so
a very nice King walk by Nigel short so
after this after this Bishop to D the
sorry Bishop to be won where was it
yeah Bishop to d1 and I shall resign the
game and this well a brilliant game but
also a weird game was played so there
you have it
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said
it's not the most precise game but it's
definitely complicated enough - to keep
a guy like Nigel off track as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
would like to thank and
and Smith for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it thank y'all for watching
and I will see you soon